Today
there are so many scientific evidence
why alcohol should be prohibited.
According to WH
in 31st July 2023
it says every in that year 2.6 million
people
died only because of intoxicants of
alcohol. 2.6 6 million people
on average in a year.
It is
one of the largest single reason
for a person to die. Alcohol
and there are various diseases. You
could only give a talk for 1 hour or
maybe 2 hours only on the diseases of
alcohol.
I'll just mention some.
It's making me revise off my medical
studies when I was in medical college
more than 30 years back.
One of the major diseases cerosis of
liver
intoxicants alcohol.
An alcoholic has high chances of cerosis
of liver can have cancer of the
esophagus of the head and neck. Cancer
of the liver,
cancer of the stomach. He can have
esophagitis.
He can have gastitis, pancreatitis,
hepatitis.
He can have cardiammyopathy.
He can have hypertension,
angina, heart attack.
He can
have
apoplelexy.
He can have fits various different types
of paralysis.
He can have strokes.
He can have peripheral neuropathy. He
can have cortical atroph atrophy. He can
have cerebal atrophy.
He can have
vernick
cos syndrome in which there is immediate
amnesia. Your immediate memory goes away
with confabulation and the permanent
memory remains because of deficiency of
thyin. He can have ber biri various
deficiency. He can have pelagra.
He can have delarium tremines in which
in acute b of alcohol on post-operative
it can even take your life.
He can have various hematological
disorders.
He can have thrombocytoenia
platus disorders.
He can have bibberry and pelagra.
The common drug that you take flag which
is metronid dissol it interacts with
alcohol.
You can have
acute
infections chronic acute infection
because your immunology defense system
is compromised. So you keep on having
infections. You can have chest
infections. You can have pneumonia. You
can have emphyma. You can have pulmon
tuberculosis.
You can
have
infection post-operatively.
And
when you're intoxicated, if you vomit,
the vomitus because there's no cough
reflex, the vomitus can go back into
your throat, can go into your lungs, can
cause emphyma,
can
can cause pulmonary distress.
You can
have
various different skin disorders.
You can have
alopeesia.
You can have nail distrophe. You can
have angloatis and the list is long. You
can keep on adding. THERE ARE SO MANY
VARIETIES of these only because of
intoxicants.
But my colleagues, I'm a medical doctor.
My colleagues, they tell me that
alcoholism is a disease. You know, you
have to be sympathetic to the po
patient. So they want to be sympathetic
towards
the alcohol. They say alcoholism is a
disease.
If alcoholism is a disease, it is the
only disease that is sold in bottles.
It's the only disease
which is advertised
in the newspapers, in the magazines, in
the radio stations, on the satellite
channels, in the social media. It is the
only disease which has official
government licensed outlets.
It's the only disease that brings
revenue for the government. If alcohol
is a disease, it's the only disease that
causes violent deaths on the highway.
It's the only disease that destroys
family. If alcohol is a disease, it is
the only disease that has no viral or
bacterial cause. It's not a disease.
Allah says first
abstain from it that you may prosper. It
is a Satan's handiwork.
It is a Satan's handiwork. Abstain from
it that may prosper.
So this was the reply to the 14th most
common question asked by the non-Muslim
regarding Islam.